[Music]
today
many members of the youtube math
community are getting together to make
videos about their favorite numbers over
1 million
and we're encouraging you the viewers to
do the same
take a look at the description for
details my own choice is considerably
larger than a million
roughly 8 times 10 to the 53. for a
sense of scale that's around the number
of atoms in the planet jupiter
so it might seem completely arbitrary
but what i love is that if you were to
talk with an alien civilization or
a super-intelligent ai that invented
math for itself without any connection
to our particular culture or
experiences i think both would agree
that this number is something very
peculiar and that it reflects something
fundamental
what is it exactly well it's the size of
the monster
but to explain what that means we're
going to need to back up and talk about
group theory
this field is all about codifying the
idea of symmetry
for example when we say a face is
symmetric what we mean
is that you can reflect it about a line
and it's left looking completely the
same
it's a statement about an action that
you can take
something like a snowflake is also
symmetric but in more ways you can
rotate it 60 degrees or 120 degrees
you can flip it along various different
axes and all these actions leave it
looking the same
a collection of all of the actions like
this taken together
is called a group kind of at least
groups are typically defined a little
more abstractly than this but we'll get
to that later
take note the fact that mathematicians
have co-opted such an otherwise generic
word
for this seemingly specific kind of
collection should give you some sense of
how fundamental they find it
also take note we always consider the
action of doing nothing to be part of
the group
so if we include that do-nothing action
the group of symmetries of a snowflake
includes 12 distinct actions it even has
a fancy name
d6 the simple group of symmetries that
only has two elements acting on a face
also has a fancy name c2
in general there is a whole zoo of
groups with no shortage of jargon to
their names categorizing the many
different ways that something can be
symmetric
when we describe these sorts of actions
there's always an implicit structure
being preserved
for example there are 24 rotations that
i can apply to a cube that leave it
looking the same
and those 24 actions taken together do
indeed constitute a group
but if we allow for reflections which is
a kind of way of saying that the
orientation of the cube
is not part of the structure we intend
to preserve you get a bigger group with
48 actions in total
if you loosen things further and
consider the faces to be a little less
rigidly attached
maybe free to rotate and get shuffled
around you would get a much larger set
of actions
and yes you could consider these
symmetries in the sense that they leave
it looking the same
and all of these shuffling rotating
actions do constitute a group
but it's a much bigger and more
complicated group
the large size in this group reflects
the much looser sense of structure which
each action preserves
the loosest sense of structure is if we
have a collection of points
and we consider any way that you could
shuffle them any permutation
to be a symmetry of those points
unconstrained by any underlying property
that needs to be preserved
these permutation groups can get quite
large here it's kind of fun to flash
through
every possible permutation of six
objects and see how many there are
[Music]
in total it amounts to 6 factorial or
720
by contrast if we gave these points some
structure maybe making them the corners
of a hexagon and
only considering the permutations that
preserve how far apart each one is from
the other
well then we only get the 12 snowflake
symmetries that we saw earlier
bump the number of points up to 12 and
the number of permutations
grows to about 479 million
the monster that we'll get to is rather
large but it's important to understand
that largeness in and of itself
is not that interesting when it comes to
groups the permutation groups already
make that easy to see
if we were shuffling 101 objects for
example
with the 101 factorial different actions
that can do this
we have a group with a size of around 9
times 10 to the 159
if every atom in the observable universe
had a copy of that universe inside
itself
this is roughly how many sub atoms there
would be
these permutation groups go by the name
s sub n
and they play a very important role in
group theory in a certain sense they
encompass
all other groups and so far you might be
thinking
okay this is intellectually playful
enough but is any of this actually
useful
one of the earliest applications of
group theory came when mathematicians
realized that the structure of these
permutation groups
tells us something about solutions to
polynomial equations
you know how in order to find the two
roots of a quadratic equation
everyone learns a certain formula in
school slightly lesser known is the fact
that there's also a cubic formula
one that involves nesting cube roots
with square roots in a larger expression
there's even a quartic formula for a
degree four polynomial
which is an absolute mess it's almost
impossible to write without factoring
things out
and for the longest time mathematicians
struggled to find a formula to solve
degree five polynomials
i mean maybe there's one but it's just
super complicated
it turns out though if you think about
the group which permutes the roots of
such a polynomial
there's something about the nature of
this group that reveals
no quintic formula can exist for example
the five roots of the polynomial you see
on screen now they have definite values
you could write out decimal
approximations
but what you can never do is write those
exact values
by starting with the coefficients of the
polynomial and using only the four basic
operations of arithmetic together with
radicals
no matter how many times you nest them
and that impossibility
has everything to do with the inner
structure of the permutation group
s5
a theme in math through the last two
centuries has been that the nature of
symmetry
in and of itself can show us all sorts
of non-obvious facts about the other
objects that we study
to give just a hint of the many many
ways that this applies to physics
there's a beautiful fact known as
notor's theorem saying that every
conservation law
corresponds to some kind of symmetry a
certain group
so all those fundamental laws like
conservation of momentum and
conservation of energy
each correspond to a group more
specifically the actions we should be
able to apply to a setup
such that the laws of physics don't
change all of this is to say that groups
really are fundamental
and the one thing i want you to
recognize right now is that they are one
of the most
natural things that you could study what
could be more universal than symmetry
so you might think that the patterns
among groups themselves would somehow be
very beautiful and symmetric
the monster however tells a different
story before we get to the monster
though
at this point some mathematicians might
complain that what i've described so far
are not groups exactly but group actions
and that groups are something slightly
more abstract
by way of analogy if i mention the
number three you probably don't think
about a specific triplet of things
you probably think about three as an
object in and of itself
an abstraction may be represented with a
symbol in much the same way
when mathematicians discuss the elements
of a group they don't necessarily think
about specific actions on specific
objects they might think of these
elements as a kind of thing in and of
itself
may be represented with a symbol for
something like the number three
the abstract symbol does us very little
good unless we define its relation with
other numbers
for example the way that it adds or that
it multiplies with them
for each of these you could think of a
literal triplet of something
but again most of us are comfortable
probably even more comfortable
using the symbols alone similarly what
makes a group
a group are all of the ways that its
elements combine with each other
and in the context of actions this has a
very vivid meaning what we mean by
combining is to apply one action
after the other read from right to left
if you flip a snowflake about the x-axis
then rotate it 60 degrees
counterclockwise the overall action is
the same as if you had flipped it about
a diagonal line
all possible ways that you can combine
two elements of a group like this
defines a kind of multiplication that is
what really gives a group its structure
here i'm drawing out the full 8x8 table
of the symmetries of a square
if you apply an action from the top row
and follow it by an action from the left
column
it'll be the same as the action in the
corresponding grid square
but if we replace each one of these
symmetric actions with something purely
symbolic
well the multiplication table still
captures the inner structure of the
group
but now it's abstracted away from any
specific object that it might act on
like a square or roots of a polynomial
this is entirely analogous to how the
usual multiplication table is written
symbolically
which abstracts away from the idea of
literal counts
literal counts arguably would make it
much clearer what's going on
but since grade school we all grow
comfortable with the symbols
after all they're less cumbersome they
free us to think about more complicated
numbers
and they also free us to think about
numbers in new and very different ways
all of this is true of groups as well
which are best understood as
abstractions above the idea of symmetry
actions
i'm emphasizing this for two reasons one
is that understanding what groups really
are gives a better appreciation for the
monster and the other
is that many students learning about
groups for the first time can find them
frustratingly opaque i know that i did a
typical course starts with this very
formal and abstract definition which is
that a group is a set
in a collection of things with a binary
operation
a notion of multiplication between those
things such that
this multiplication satisfies four
special rules or axioms
and all of this can feel well kind of
random
especially when it isn't made clear that
all of these axioms arise from the
things that must obviously be true when
you're thinking about actions and
composing them
to any students among you with such a
course in the future i would say if you
appreciate that the relationship groups
have with symmetric actions
is analogous to the relationship numbers
have with counts
it can help to make the course a lot
more grounded an example might help to
see why this kind of abstraction is
desirable
consider the symmetries of a cube and
the permutation group of four objects
at first these groups feel very
different you might think of the one on
the left
as acting on eight corners in a way that
preserves the distance and orientation
structure among them but on the right we
have a completely unconstrained set of
actions
on a much smaller set of points as it
happens though
these two groups are really the same in
the sense that their multiplication
tables will look identical
anything that you can say about one
group will be true
of the other for example there are eight
distinct permutations
where applying it three times in a row
gets you back to where you started
not counting the identity these are the
ones that cycle three different elements
together
there are also eight rotations of the
cube that have this property
the various 120 and 240 degree rotations
about each diagonal
this is no coincidence the way to phrase
this more precisely is to say there is a
one-to-one mapping
between rotations of a cube and
permutations of four elements
which preserves composition for example
rotating 180 degrees about the y-axis
followed by 180 degrees about the x-axis
gives the same overall effect as
rotating 180 degrees around the z-axis
remember that's what we mean by a
product of two actions
and if you look at the corresponding
permutations under a certain one-to-one
association
this product will still be true applying
the two actions on the left
gives the same overall effect as the one
on the right
when you have a correspondence where
this remains true for all products
it's called an isomorphism which is
maybe the most important idea in group
theory
this particular isomorphism between cube
rotations and
permutations of four objects is a bit
subtle but for the curious among you you
may enjoy taking a moment to think hard
about how the rotations of a cube
permute its four diagonals
in your mathematical life you'll see
more examples of a given group
arising from seemingly unrelated
situations and as you do
you'll get a better sense for what group
theory is all about
think about how a number like three is
not really about a particular triplet of
things
it's about all possible triplets of
things in the same way
a group is not really about symmetries
of a particular object
it's an abstract way that things even
can be symmetric
there are even plenty of situations
where groups come up in a way that does
not feel like a set of symmetric actions
at all
just as numbers can do a lot more than
count in fact
seeing the same group come up in
different situations is a great way to
reveal
unexpected connections between distinct
objects that's a very common theme in
modern math
and once you understand this about
groups it leads you to a natural
question
which will eventually lead to the
monster what are
all the groups but now you're in a
position to ask that question in a more
sophisticated way
what are all the groups up to
isomorphism which is to say we consider
two groups to be the same
if there's an isomorphism between them
this is asking something more
fundamental than what are all the
symmetric things
it's a way of asking what are all the
ways that something can be symmetric
is there some formula or procedure for
producing them all
some meta-pattern lying at the heart of
symmetry itself
this question turns out to be hard
exceedingly hard
for one thing there's the division
between infinite groups for example the
ones describing the symmetries of a line
or
a circle and finite groups like the ones
we've looked at up to this point
to maintain some hope of sanity let's
limit our view to finite groups
in the same way that numbers can be
broken down into their prime
factorization
or molecules can be described based on
the atoms within them
there's a certain way that finite groups
can be broken down into a kind of
composition of smaller groups
the ones which can't be broken down any
further analogous to prime numbers or
atoms
are known as the simple groups to give a
hint for why this is useful
remember how we said that group theory
can be used to prove that there's no
formula for a degree five polynomial
the way there is for quadratic equations
well if you're wondering what that proof
actually looks like
it involves showing that if there were
some kind of mythical quintic formula
something which uses only radicals and
the basic arithmetic operations
it would imply that the permutation
group on five elements
decomposes into a special kind of simple
group known fancifully as the cyclic
groups of prime order
but the actual way that this breaks down
involves a different kind of simple
group
a different kind of atom one which
polynomial solutions built from radicals
would never allow that is a super high
level description of course with about a
semester's worth of details missing
but the point is that you have this
really not obvious fact about a
different part of math
whose solutions come from finding the
atomic structure of a certain group
this is one of many different examples
where understanding the nature of these
simple groups these atoms
actually matters outside of group theory
the task of categorizing
all finite groups breaks down into two
steps one
find all the simple groups and two find
all of the ways to combine
them the first question is like finding
the periodic table
and the second is a bit like doing all
of chemistry thereafter
the good news is that mathematicians
have found all of the finite simple
groups
well more pertinent is that they proved
that the ones that they found
are in fact all the ones out there it
took
many decades tens of thousands of dense
pages of advanced math
hundreds of some of the smartest minds
out there and significant help from
computers
but by 2004 with a culminating 12 000
pages to tie up the loose ends
there was a definitive answer many
experts agree
this is one of the most monumental
achievements in the history of math
the bad news though is that the answer
is absurd
there are 18 distinct infinite families
of simple groups
which makes it really tempting to lean
into the whole periodic table analogy
but groups are stranger than chemistry
because there are also these 26 simple
groups
that are just left over they don't fit
the other patterns
these 26 are known as the sporadic
groups that a field of study rooted in
symmetry itself
has such a patched together fundamental
structure is
well i mean it's just bizarre it's like
the universe was designed by committee
if you're wondering what we mean by an
infinite family examples might help
one such family of simple groups
includes all of these cyclic groups with
prime order
these are essentially the symmetries of
a regular polygon with a prime number of
sides
but where you're not allowed to flip the
polygon over
another of these infinite families is
very similar to the permutation groups
that we saw earlier
but there's the tiniest constraint on
how they're allowed to shuffle n
items if they act on five or more
elements
these groups are simple which
incidentally is heavily related to why
polynomials with degree five or more
have solutions that can't be written
down using radicals
the other 16 families are notably more
complicated and i'm told that there's at
least a little ambiguity in how to
organize them into cleanly distinct
families without overlap
but what everybody agrees on is that the
26 sporadic groups
stand out as something very different
the largest of these sporadic
groups is known thanks to john conway as
the monster group
and its size is the number i mentioned
at the start
the second largest and i promise this
isn't a joke is known as the baby
monster group
together with the baby monster 19 of
these sporadic groups are in a certain
sense
children of the monster and robert
greece called these 20 the happy family
he also called the other six which don't
even fit that pattern
the pariahs as if to compensate for how
complicated the underlying
math here is the experts really let
loose on their whimsy while naming
things
let me emphasize having a group which is
big is not that big a deal
but the idea that one of the fundamental
building blocks for one of the most
fundamental ideas in math
comes in a collection that just abruptly
stops around 8 times 10 to the 53
that's weird now at this point given
that i introduced groups as
symmetries a collection of actions you
might wonder
what it is that the monster acts on what
object does it describe the symmetries
of
well there is an answer but it doesn't
fit into two or three dimensions to draw
nor does it fit into four or five
instead
to see what the monster acts on we would
have to jump up to
wait for it 196
883 dimensions just describing
one of the elements of this group takes
about four gigabytes of data
even though plenty of groups that are
way bigger have a much smaller
computational description
the permutation group on 101 elements
was if you'll recall
dramatically bigger but we can describe
each one of its elements with very
little data
for example a list of 100 numbers
no one really understands why the
sporadic groups and the monster in
particular
are there maybe in a few decades there
will be a clearer answer
maybe one of you will come up with it
but despite knowing that they are deeply
fundamental to math and arguably to
physics as well
a lot about them remains mysterious in
the 1970s mathematician john mckay was
making a switch from studying group
theory to an adjacent field
and he noticed that a number very
similar to this 19683
showed up in a completely unrelated
context or at least
almost a number one bigger than this was
in the series expansion of a fundamental
function
in a totally different part of math
relevant to these things called modular
forms and elliptic functions
assuming that this was more than a
coincidence seemed crazy enough that it
was playfully deemed moonshine by john
conway
but after more numerical coincidences
like this were noticed it gave rise to
what became known as the monstrous
moonshine conjecture
whimsical names just don't stop this was
proved by richard borchards in 1992
solidifying a connection between very
different parts of math that at first
glance seemed crazy
six years later by the way he won the
fields medal in part for the
significance of this proof
and related to this moonshine is a
connection between the monster and
string theory
maybe it shouldn't come as a surprise
that something that arises from symmetry
itself
is relevant to physics but in light of
just how random the monster seems at
first glance
this connection still elicits a double
take
to me the monster and its absurd size is
a nice reminder that fundamental objects
are not necessarily simple
the universe doesn't really care if its
final answers look clean
they are what they are by logical
necessity with no concern over how
easily we'll be able to understand them
[Music]
you